welcome to this video playing raspy Aruk
Nick from the Netherlands one of the
more frequent opponents I have played
seven games against him and I only
scored um I don't really understand it I
mean the statistics it says overall
score mmm wow I cannot calculate sorry I
have seventy percent against the guy I
was just terribly miscalculating from
further from a mathematical point of
view and what what opening is he playing
here this looks really strange if I go e
5 e 5 here what is he doing Knight g4 I
mean I can even take which is not bad
okay give me five night yeah yeah wow
yeah now threatening to take and play
Queen age five okay interesting yeah but
okay I cannot avoid a queen trade let's
start with that they I cannot allow a
free trade while it's got me all
confused that I didn't manage to
understand that three and a half out of
five or seventy percent the sir it's
Bowie yet ok so this place my IDM this
set up attacking the porn you know I
should get to age five but he's got my
g4 actually
94 that's not bad
I wonder what do you know it does not go
there that's strange Knight g4 would
have been good too I guess check now I
get to get this check in okay so night
f-4s deserve a possible move maybe okay
let's develop stuff I want to go to f4
with this night anyway that's a good
good spot yeah of course he's um he's
very uncoordinated with the king only
seven yeah I can take now but it's not
really great young but or not well now I
have 94 isn't this sort of dangerous
with night f5 and 96 it looks dangerous
I can take care right something better
no I don't think so I mean I'm
threatening a ton of discover chicks IAM
just check yeah and again the King needs
to go somewhere uncomfortable I get this
check king here Bishop f7 and he needs
to play GF I if I this is very ugly but
there's no reason not to first complete
development and now maybe h4 h5 this
this type of thing orgy form yeah it's
not bad reform but okay I many many good
ways to play the ship here are then it
takes that's not good
yeah still I have h5 is there something
and it feels like there should be
something something are decisive 94
maybe a 94 takes bishop tags are that's
actually winning that's winning I think
edwins that's nice g5 in the mix and if
he takes Bishop takes g6 Queen f7 is
winning King g8 is queen bee three and
it said it's a crossfire yeah that's
winning um Bishop Bishop it was right
yes sufficiently yeah g6 Queen f7 is
easy and King g8 queen bee three years
also also nice yeah but there was too
much was simply too much going on with
blacks king okay so quinta exam check g6
is an instant made and planet recently
ages checkmates this cube mate yeah he
had the health of opportunity to get an
excellent position i was i was in this
sub 0 confused state i could have taken
here and play Knight to g4 which is
actually great for black just attacking
you five and how do I protect the spawn
even it's very dry tricky if I go here
for example yes yeah and and I'm really
I've really in trouble I will lose my
all-important d5 pawn and i already have
given up the bishops yeah this was the
the golden opportunity that he M that he
had I must play move like something like
that not um Bishop c4 which exposes my
position far too much this still seems
fairly playable maybe something like
that if I take it let's queen bee six
very funny position yeah this this would
have been a big fight and after that
watch is just just much better of course
I don't want to trade queens oh here you
can play Knight b6 this I must prevent
this still would have been okay for
black so this was a bad move I need to
go here I guess so that after Knight b6
I can move the Queen away okay it's much
more precise so right here I'm just do
again long cancels and the computer is
not playing night in form or hy plate
wants to play e 6 which it is very
strong now of course I'm just getting
this home and this is terrible yeah okay
this is much stronger even and here 94
is the winner yet it is I didn't
miscalculate anything here yeah it's
just it's just gone I mean he has no
move if he moves the Queen there is
chance one check checkmate nice and yeah
of course if you to complete that just
check this is a check by the roof and
jack oops not that one sorry I first
need to dig of course and then
I have this coming up check and do
something like that but also when ya 94
was a nice shot check and here this was
the important you see that you have this
side step with the Queen and this winter
winds the house you must play this one
chanting this wins everything as bishop
e6 is a checkmate director made in one
yeah was lucky in this opening really
this this was very strange or this that
he went four for this year maybe I
should just take that's it that's
possible but this could be playable
actually 96 and castles look so strange
but probably this is ok just here ok I
went I went here maybe this is a mistake
Knight f3 yeah this is better why not
just develop taking at a recapture here
this is very nice looking at those
squares alright thanks for watching